hey youtubers is Charlie so big news
they're like some Secret Wars real civil
wars going on inside Marvel right now
basically what's happening is is Kevin
Feige is no longer working for the Jay
jonah Jameson of Marvel Entertainment
and he is now moving into the Disney
Avengers tower with another boss there's
even some reports that Kevin Feige could
potentially go to the Star Wars universe
after a Kathleen Kennedy leaves her job
at Lucasfilm now it sounds like with all
the drama that's going on Kevin Feige is
staying put where he is through through
phase 4 I don't see Kathleen Kennedy
quitting her job anytime soon like
they're just getting started with Star
Wars but Kevin Feige could end up doing
the same thing with the Star Wars
universe that he's done with the Marvel
Cinematic Universe like he's just like a
master at organizing all these films
together so business stuff first like
what's what's going on like what's all
this drama that everyone's talking about
maybe you guys have heard recently about
Disney restructuring Marvel
Entertainment just a little bit the only
thing that's changed is just who the
people that make the movies report to
you may or may not have heard of some of
these big executives but when most
people think about Marvel movies they
think about Kevin Feige he's the
president of the studio but he has a
boss and his boss has a boss if he'd
been around long enough you may have
remembered that Marvel almost went
bankrupt
Marvel Comics almost went bankrupt back
in the 90s now back then the business
was very different it had already passed
through a couple hands like the company
is being sold up it was in a very bad
place a group of people bought the
company for I think it was like 84 or 85
million dollars and then took it public
with the money that they made from going
public they bought a couple other
businesses associated with comics like
you know like toy businesses trading
cards other things that they could put
Marvel characters on and sell you know
think things to make money one of those
companies was called toy biz the two
people that own that company were a V
Arad and Ike Perlmutter now you probably
recognize a v-rod's name he's one of the
founders of Marvel Studios the film arm
of Marvel Entertainment that really
started with the spider-man movies but
Marvel Studios when it first started was
very different than what it is right now
it wasn't a full studio then in 1998
that company that Avi Arad owned in Ike
Perlmutter merged with Marvel and it
forms something called Marvel
enterprises one of those divisions was
Marvel Studios so that's really when
they got super serious about making
movie
remember though a lot of the characters
rights had been sold off so they're
making movies with Sony making movies
with Universal like the hold films Kevin
Feige was brought on and we got our
phase 1 phase 2 now phase 3 but through
all these weird business mergers and
bankruptcies Ike Perlmutter had been
named the new CEO but a lot of the
creative success and organization is
attributed to Kevin Feige most of the
weirdness and the criticism you hear
about going on with the movies has more
to do with Ike promoter Kevin Feige his
boss there are a lot of rumors that he's
thrown like a lot a lot of wrenches and
a lot of Kevin Feige G's ideas and plans
and they clashed heads a lot there was
even a moment last year where a quote
was attributed to him that he didn't
think that female led superhero movies
would sell so a lot of people think that
Kevin Feige is boss is the reason why we
haven't seen like a female lead
superhero movie like he just doesn't
think that it'll be profitable
which is ridiculous obviously so what's
happened now is the chairman of Disney
who now owns Marvel Entertainment who
owns that entire company has taken Kevin
Feige in Marvel Studios and said you
don't need to report to anyone now but
me so it's like Mickey Mouse is reaching
in and taking the wrench out of the
engine that is Marvel Studios what is
all this Disney restructuring mean for
people like you and me they're like
people that go see the movies not a
whole lot right now more towards the end
of phase 3 and phase 4 yes there will be
a phase 4 and a lot of that I think is
because the actors will now come back
because of the changes they made behind
the scenes a lot of the actors contracts
were gonna be up real soon like Chris
Evans Chris Hemsworth they do make a lot
of money they're big actors but they
could make more money doing other movies
with another studio
there was actually a report that Kevin
Feige Szold boss was so cheap that he
made Chris Evans pay for his gym
membership his own gym membership when
they were working on the first Avengers
film typically what you see with big
actors is they get a lot of writers on
their contracts where it's like you know
we'll give you a trailer we'll give you
these basic amenities for the six months
that you're working on this film but
because Marvel Studios was originally
born out of this bankrupt Marvel
Corporation and Ike Perlmutter who's a
businessman who takes companies out of
bankruptcy was was in charge of
everything he's just like we're not
spending money on anything so it'd be
like you renting an apartment and
getting just like like a paper box on
the side of the street
now that Feige in Marvel Studios has a
little more freedom in terms of the
decisions that it makes
the ways that it spends money most
people feel like the bigger actors will
come back and Reese I knew contracts
there's one other really big casualty of
all this - it's Marvel's creative group
if you've never heard of them before
it's a group of writers that advise on
all the films so what'll happen is is
when they're developing a new film
people like Brian Michael Bendis like a
couple other people it's not a huge
group it's pretty small but Bendis is
one of the people on it they'll give
notes on every single draft of every
script that is written like hey this
character wouldn't do this hey this
story line from the comics was more like
this there's a rumor that a lot of the
filmmakers totally hated this creative
group they say that it caused more
problems than its solved like they would
argue over really small plot points and
ignore the general tone of films like
Edgar Wright had a big problem with them
whether or not that's true doesn't
matter but it sounds like that group has
been disbanded some of you might say it
helps to have a group of comic book
nerds advising on films but sometimes
you can see how they would just argue
with each other and it would hurt things
what about the Star Wars news though
what's what's up with that like Kevin
Feige going to Star Wars well there's a
lot of people that said you know before
this restructuring like he had been like
butting heads with his boss so much when
his contract was up which was gonna be
up at the end of phase 3 then instead of
trying to do a phase 4 with Marvel he
would go to the Star Wars universe and
work with them what does one of the most
powerful comic book nerds in the film
business do when he doesn't want to work
with Marvel anymore
well he'd either go to DC and Warner
Brothers or he would go to Star Wars
those are the two next best things you
could possibly do being that Disney owns
both Marvel and Star Wars it just makes
sense that he would stay inside the
house of mouse Disney is all about
holding on to talent now that they own
all these big brands they own Star Wars
Lucasfilm Pixar it's a lot easier to
keep actors around just because they can
send them to other divisions they're
like hey do you want to do a Pixar film
do you want to be in a Disney film now
but one of the things that's probably
not changing is Marvel's television
group is probably staying the way it is
right now
they still report to Kevin Feige old
boss whether that's bad or good remains
to be seen depending on how you feel
about Marvel television they handle
everything from what you see on ABC like
agents of shield to the Netflix stuff
like daredevil Luke Cage iron fist all
that stuff Thank You Kevin Feige is
being like Peter Parker - Ike Perlmutter
CA jonah Jameson at the Daily Bugle
Peter Parker is moving in with the
Avengers which is kind of funny because
now they have the agreement with Sony a
lot of people say that I promote her
almost torched that deal with Sony and
he almost cost them Robert Downey jr.
rut like Robert Downey jr. was ready to
leave Marvel films but but I think that
they were able to work in an agreement
with Captain America's Civil War and it
all ended up being fine but because of
this executive meddling which is now
arguably over like that era is over it
almost cost them some of their biggest
actors it's kind of like the owner of a
basketball team meddling with the coach
like you hire an amazing coach they have
a really winning season but the owner
who may not know anything about
basketball keeps changing decisions so
no more of that you guys can let me know
though if Kevin Feige worked to ever
leave Marvel Studios like not make any
more Marvel films would you want to see
him go to Star Wars and help that brand
like make that expanded universe or
would you rather see him go to Warner
Brothers and try to do the same thing
with the DC movies that he did with the
Marvel movies but like I said in like 5
to 10 years he'll probably just go to
the Star Wars universe Disney will just
have a lot more money than anyone else
to offer him so in related news really
big stuff I'm gonna be talking about
Star Wars stuff on the schmoes podcast
tonight I don't have a link right now
but as soon as I do I'll just I'll paste
it into the description and I'll get
I'll post it all over social media so
look out for that if you guys don't know
about force Friday there's a lot of Star
Wars Episode 7 toy stuff happening this
weekend I'm gonna do a video for that as
soon as I get back from doing the
schmoes podcast there's some more arrow
Green Lantern stuff I'm gonna be talking
about maybe another Marvel video there's
a lot of really exciting stuff and
there's some big Doctor Who news too for
any of you that are big River Song fans
so I'll be talking about that the next
day or two
so while you guys wait for all that
stuff to post you can click here to
learn about the teams in Captain America
Civil War and you can click here for my
top 10 spider-man costumes from the
comics thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you